i had to take out student loans so that
i could be able to go to college
thus far that mission has cost me 88 000
i just think gosh couldn't there have
been a better way
my name is marvin logan and i have a
mountain of student loan debt
i'm a first generation college student i
was an all-american track and field
athlete in high school and due to those
merits i was able to earn a track and
field scholarship and then i got hurt
and that changed everything i had to
take out student loans to be able to
compensate for the athletic scholarship
that i had lost by the time that i
graduate with my masters i'll be closer
to a hundred thousand dollars in debt i
certainly think that it was worth it but
it was a high price to pay to have a
better life
what is most important for me is that i
can take the experiences that i've
learned and teach them to my students
i work as a program assistant for
usher's new look which is a non-profit
organization all about youth development
and leadership
one of the things that i do with my work
is help students evaluate and navigate
student loans financial aid figuring out
how to make the best choices when going
off to college so they can continue to
develop as leaders
part of the reason that we've come to
the circumstances we have in college
affordability is our lack of
representation not just as young people
but it's people in general they're
probably not too many things that are
more important
in this world than to stand up and be
counted if you truly want to be stronger
together
if you truly want to make america great
again
you won't be able to do that without a
solid and sound investment in education
you